hi I'm Christopher hin and today we're
going to be talking about what to do
when someone doesn't worry about your
weapon hand now in iido the syllabus the
way it's built there's a lot of focus on
the weapon arm but that doesn't mean
that they're always going to not check
your weapon arm and we could say that
well if they don't check our weapon arm
I'm going to use my weapon on them so
that that's bad for them and we're right
that is bad for them but the problem is
it could still also be bad for you so uh
I know this is kind of a a fuzzy
description right now but when we get
into it I'll show you what I mean and
we'll talk about some different
scenarios that'll come up and this will
help when you start actually getting
into a lot of live rondor so I'm going
to call Josh over here and we're going
to go to work Josh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so uh now we're going to talk
about a subject that I don't have a
clear-cut title to tell you it's it's
you know what do I do when he ignores my
uh weapon hand all right so um this will
come up a ton for you guys in rondor uh
and I I wish I had an easier thing to to
describe it as because anytime you get a
good term for something then it makes it
clear but I'll roughly give this to you
and as soon as I get a good good term
for it all I'll tell you what it is but
um so so understand that you know we're
doing rondor so I'm running around Josh
trying to catch me and I'm popping him
with the stick bang bang bang bang bang
okay what Josh is doing right now is the
normal thing which is he's accounting
for my weapon hand right and that's how
all the iido forms expect him to do that
right so I go like this bang bang now if
he got his way maybe he would grab my
wrist right or going to EO right so but
he he's going to do something that has
to do with my arm and we account for
that all the time in iido okay now what
if though I hit him and immediately
after he just comes and hits my body or
ignores my hand totally and comes gets
my body right so Josh just ignores the
attack and gets my body what do I do
does iido have answers for that okay
while I think pretty much across Styles
I mean there might be some some some
styles that I was going to say lesser
Styles I'm saying lesser not because the
style is less important but just because
it's not as known there might be some
lesser styles that have that in them I
don't I don't know that they do though
but iido does have answers for that so
the basic answer for any wide position
in iido is a to maintain my Inner Space
okay now I often do that with a strike
to the face or any kind of push to the
core that that moves me away from his
body and then I try and angle on that
now if I do what I just did right now so
now I got enough room that I could get
by this then I would get by that if I
cannot do that right so his arms are
really long or something then I try to
shoot uchim moari right and that's why
we have uchim marari in the system so
that's what the system is saying about
any time they come to get your body like
that they come wide around you okay so
in this situation say I come to hit Josh
here and he comes in inside of me one
thing I can do is drop my elbow right in
here and this elbow keeps him from
getting too too tight to me right so uh
I'm I'm just creating a little space
here with my elbow now the reason I'm
doing is because my weapon hands already
out here like this and as he comes in I
come down and I try and stop him here on
the weapon side and then from here I'm
going to work out in any number of ways
right so if I could just push my body
out wide enough to pass the arm then I
could pass the arm if I can't do that
then maybe I'm going to press on that
face and get out with a proper triangle
right so I'm going to use a proper
triangle to get out of there could be
that as I come up Josh defends this top
and then he slides down around my arm
right okay now this is bad because it
really neutralizes a lot of this arm as
he does it and I can get caught that way
right and so it can be hard to go from
here to shoot it in here because he's
connected to my arm right okay so what
you have to try to do and this is
difficult is shoot this hand across your
body as you turn your hips now you can't
just do this because you're going to be
in two week of position to do anything
you have to rotate your hips as you're
doing that and so what happens is as
Josh is coming in watch what'll happen
I'll go right across his face and then I
can push myself out to the long side now
preferably all the times when you're
doing that you want to be non weapon
side forward to him and you want to do
it so you're always headed to his back
right now let me let me explain what I
mean okay so here I'm headed towards
Josh's back so this is Ion me right I
don't know if you guys you know like a
lot of times when we'll be in positions
like this is Ion me right but you might
not recognize it because it doesn't look
like a really strict rigid Hy now the
reason I want to be in this position is
because when I'm hitting him there's
nothing to defend him back here right
all of his tools to defend him is this
way right so if we were in yakui like
this as I'm hitting him you see there's
everything's there to defend me and so I
or defend him so I can't really get
successful weapon hits and my weapon is
always right where he is and so that's
no good I don't want that so I want my
weapon side back and I want to be in
this configuration where I'm headed to
his back side so if if possible I always
want to be an ihon me so that's why our
triangle should come off like this and
our triangle shouldn't come off like
this this is not a triangle right and
the reason is because it's not as useful
for me right even if I had the weapon
over here every time I go to hit him he
can defend that really really easily so
I want to have the weapon always at his
backside now I do risk my backside for
that Advantage but it's a good trade
because my weapon's going to be more
successful and I'm also always moving
forward which is an important thing to
understand so when we're here like this
as I go to get Josh I'm moving forward
into Josh if I'm in this position when I
go to move forward into Josh it's no
good because he's right there with me
right now if I have to get away from
Josh I have to move backwards right so
look if Josh is threatening my weapon I
pull it away I'm moving backwards which
means Josh in the dominant position that
is not the case here as Josh comes to
get me I'm getting away from from Josh
forward right so always a better trade
for me so I would always prefer to be in
that ihon me position and ihon me can be
sneaky if we let's make a nice one so
they can see so here's a nice ihon right
but if we're both standing kind of
squarish you might not recognize this is
ihon me but this is the preferable
position to be in over this position
which is gaku right okay so when they're
coming to get you one thing you need to
do is keep space in between you're going
to put something in there that can be
done either by your elbow sneaking in
here or shooting your hand in there to
push them away when you do it though you
always need to be the side so that
you're an ihon me and you're working
towards their back forward and not
working away from them backwards and you
don't want to be hitting into traffic
traffic is the term I use for meaning
there's something there to stop me I
want to be hitting where there's no
traffic in into his backside so that's
always what I'm looking for when I'm
lining this stuff up all right so this
is a it's a weird kind of Hodge pody of
things but it's something that we've
done for years a lot of things that Josh
and I do naturally in our rondor because
we spent lots of years in the garage
smashing each other around that I have
to convey to people who haven't spent
that time and it's like boy I we just
kind of figured out how to do that you
know and so I don't know what to tell
you to call that that thing but so I've
been lately really trying to figure out
how you strip those things out better
and talk about them clearly instead of
just having your students do a ton of
rondor which I think is a good idea but
that's not always convenient not always
the best way to get into it so that's a
little bit on this what happens if they
don't check your weapon hand i'm
Christoph Hine this is Joshua te my
McDaniel is actually behind that one
right now thank you very much
[Music]